on va voir justement comment ça se passe
du côté de carquive où l'on retrouve
l'envoyé spécial de France 24 Mélina
Huet bonsoir bonjour Mélina vous êtes
allés à la rencontre de la population
qui vit tout près de la ligne de front
alors est-ce qu'ils ont vu eux
alors non pas du tout alors nous
trouvons dans la ville de harkish mais
toute la journée nous étions à la
frontière entre la région de rakif et
celle de louansk à 2 km de la ligne de
front avec des soldes nous avons pu
échanger avec des populations qui vivent
dans des villages alentours et tous sans
exception nous le disent nous le
confirme il n'y a pas eu de trêve de
Noël nous avons parlé par exemple à
l'Aude Mila qui disait que qui
s'énervait un petit peu quand on lui
posait la question la trêve elle disait
mais la trêve elle n'est qu'à la
télévision moi j'habite dans ce village
en réalité il n'y a eu aucun arrêt des
frappes encore ce matin j'en ai entendu
c'est systématique alors j'en entends
parler dans les médias de cette trêve
mais elle n'existe pas et elle elle a
conclu en disant que de toute façon pour
elle il n'était il était impossible de
faire confiance à Vladimir Poutine
qu'elle a traité de menteurs nous avons
également parlé à Olga une grand-mère
qui nous disait mais encore ce matin on
a entendu cinq frappes et je peux vous
dire ce que j'habite ici depuis très
longtemps et que j'étais là pendant la
totalité de l'occupation puisque dans
cette région il y a qui a été libérée à
la fin de l'été au début de l'automne
dernier il y a eu plusieurs mois
d'occupation nous disaient impossible
pour nous de croire à une trêve elle
n'existe pas elle n'existe que dans la
tête des Russes et nous avons parlé
également à Taras alors lui il a un
profil intéressant puisque il était tout
petit lors de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
lorsque le crâne était encore dans
l'Union soviétique et elle nous disait
en fait pour nous c'est très symbolique
parce que quand j'étais petit nous
combattons pour et aux côtés de Staline
et en ce moment nous combattons pour la
liberté des factos ce n'est pas
seulement sur des témoignages que repose
ce non respect du de du cessez-le-feu de
cette trêve de Noël puisque nous nous
sommes rendus donc à 2 km de la ligne de
front et les frappes sont incessantes
d'un côté comme de l'autre alors quand
on parle avec les soldats et qu'on leur
dit mais pas non plus vous ne respectez
pas ce ciel c'est le feu il nous disent
écoutez il y a eu un cessez le feu soit
disant en avril qui n'a pas non plus été
respecté alors il est hors de question
pour nous de ne pas riposter aux frappes
qui en réalité n'ont jamais cessé on
leur a demandé à partir de quand le
cesser le feu a été interrompu mais
c'est fait n'existe tout simplement pas
des soldats qui nous expliquent qu'il
s'agit d'une stratégie à tout le monde
pour le commandement russe soit pour
déployer des hommes soit pour les
réorganiser et puis surtout il parle
d'une communication ils disent que pour
Vladimir Poutine et bien cela le permet
de se de se faire poser comme un grand
samaritain finalement qui permet aux
gens de fêter le Noël orthodoxe or et
bien cette trêve n'existe pas et pour il
n'y aura pas de trèfle possible et pas
de pour parler de paix tant que les
Russes resteront sur leur territoire
merci beaucoup pour toutes ces
précisions Mélina a eu être qui est en
direct depuis arrives en
Ukraine